on everyone we're gonna come around here
where are we going and we're gonna go up
around here we're going we're going to
wwdc
okay so i'm a little out of practice
with people and in person apple events
since i've been watching from my
basement for two years but i'm here i
did it i'm at apple's worldwide
developers conference to watch the
keynote
on this screen
tim is it okay with you if i wear
slippers
i'm jealous okay i promise this video is
not about my first time back at an
in-person apple event
it's about the two-hour pre-recorded
keynote apple held to announce updates
to
ios 16 let's talk about watch os this
year in ipad os 16 we have a big release
mac os ventura enriches so many of the
ways we use our macs just like every
year there are hundreds of new software
updates coming to your apple gadgets
this fall and apple also threw in a new
hardware upgrade an all new macbook air
completely redesigned around m2 here are
the eight announcements i'm most excited
about
number one a new macbook air introducing
m2 that's right new laptop new chip the
air has a new m2 chip which is as you
guessed it a lot faster according to
charts it delivers 18 greater
performance but i'm more excited about
the total redesign of this 2.7 pound
fanless laptop it's been totally slimmed
down and like the macbook pros it brings
back the magsafe charging connector
oh wow it's really really light it will
not drop this and of course colors
silver space gray a gorgeous star light
and a stunning midnight it's not your
old macbook air either yes it's got a
notch surrounding the new 1080p webcam
and a slightly larger 13-inch screen
overall the best part might be the
optional power adapter it has two usbc
ports so you can plug in your iphone or
other gadget and simultaneously charge
both this one comes with the higher end
1499 macbook air model but you could
also upgrade for 20
the air will be available in july
number two a new iphone lock screen say
bye to your boring lock screen with ios
16 you'll be able to change the font and
color of the time and date i think this
looks awesome now plus you can add
widgets including weather and with
widget kit developers can create their
own widgets for the lock screen and so
you can see all of those the
notifications now pop up from the bottom
of the screen ios 16 is only available
for those with the iphone 8 or later
sorry anyone with an older iphone number
three messaging features
finally you can now mark any thread as
unread okay i'm super into this one
since i'm constantly forgetting about
messages now i'll be able to mark them
as unread and know to come back to them
then there are two new features for
those times when you flub a message
you'll be able to edit a message or
recall the message entirely now you have
undo send but only for up to 15 minutes
after sending it number four pass keys
no one likes passwords but what about
pass keys pass keys use biometric
sensors in your device touch id face id
to authenticate logins that means you
don't need to create a password or try
to remember it when you make an online
account with a supported device but
you'll need an apple device to prove
your identity we've designed pass keys
to work at apps as easily as they do on
the web pass keys are securely synced
across apple devices using icloud
keychain we've been working with
industry leaders in the fido alliance
including google and microsoft to ensure
that pass keys work seamlessly
cross-platform if it sounds confusing i
know but this is all an industry effort
to work towards a new safer
password-less standard number five
new car play okay so we didn't see an
apple car but the next version of
carplay looks totally awesome it
basically replaces all the crap from
your car maker the radio interface
climate control speedometer everything
on the dashboard in fact this next
generation of carplay powers your entire
instrument cluster
to do this your iphone communicates with
your vehicle's real-time systems in an
on-device
privacy-friendly way
except no one is getting this anytime
soon car makers will need to build it
into their new models
vehicles will start to be announced late
next year number six medication
reminders well the name says it all with
watch os 9 and ios 16 you'll be able to
put your medications into the health app
and set reminders to take them you can
log medications that you might take
occasionally like civilizing for
allergies and you can receive
notifications for medications that you
need to take regularly you can even use
the iphone camera to scan the label of
the medication
number seven continuity camera with the
new mac os ventura and ios 16 you can
finally do something i've been doing for
the last two years use your iphone's
camera as your webcam
now for an odd but technically
impressive feature it's called desk view
and it uses the iphone's ultra wide
camera to show a bird's eye view of your
desk i didn't even need to adjust my
phone it looks cool i mean until you
leave out some confidential paper or i
don't know your hemorrhoid cream sadly
this fancy iphone clip sold separately
number eight stage manager okay ipad
users here's another one that will make
your tablet more like a real computer
with ios 16 a feature called stage
manager will actually let you use ipad
apps like windows you can resize them
and have them overlap and if you have an
ipad pro or air with an m1 chip you can
get full external display support with
resolutions up to 6k
[Music]
all right well i survived
going
home with my slippers on